gut dann können wir beginnen wir werden
uns heute mit leibniz nochmal fassen und
zwar über seine theorie c werden wir
diskutieren und in dieser schrift über
die theodizee geht vor allem über das
böse ich hatte ihn ja gesagt ich biete
in diesem semester noch ein seminar wird
das böse an
wir wollen jetzt mal schauen ob wir bei
leibnitz nicht auch noch etwas über das
gut finden müssen jetzt ganz genau
hinschauen
so war es finden und dennoch müssen wir
uns mit der frage nach dem bösen
beschäftigen
ich habe ja noch mal die leitfragen kurz
angegeben wie erklärt leibnitz die
existenz des übels in der welt
warum ist der auffassung dass wir zu den
besten aller möglichen welten befinden
die fans diese auffassung problematisch
wir hängen nach leibnitz gut und böse in
der besten aller möglichen welten
miteinander zusammen das ist die frage
die wir uns stellen wollen
sagen sie mal kurz was ist eine mögliche
welt nach leibnitz dass es noch mal ganz
wichtig mögliche welt geben sie mir ein
beispiel für eine mögliche kommen ja
genau
eine welt die in sich keine logischen
widersprüche enthält das ist eine
mögliche wird man könnte auch sagen denk
mögliche welt was wäre dann eine
unmögliche welt geben sie mal mögliches
beispiel ja
genau oder vielleicht sogar aber da bin
ich mir nicht ganz sicher aber nach
leibnitz wäre dass da bin ich mit doch
sicher eine unmögliche bild wenn es eine
welt gebe in der jeder von uns zweimal
vor kennen und genau identisch wäre oder
noch ein beispiel eine welt in der zwei
gegenstände in jeder hinsicht identisch
sind aber eben zwei sind bleibt es geht
das nicht verletzt ist es so wenn zwei
gegenstände in jeder hinsicht identisch
sind dann sind sie miteinander identisch
das leibniz gesetz kann sich fragen ob
es nicht doch möglich wäre bereit
gezeigt von zwei gegenstände genau
identisch sind
in dieser eigenschaft jeder hinsicht
dann sind sie miteinander identischen
entfallen sie zusammen wenn man sich
eine welt 14 der ist wirklich 20
identische gegenstände gäbe dann wäre
das jedenfalls gegen leibnitz logische
auffassung nach leibnitz wäre das an
eine unmögliche rentieren
auf der wirtschaft gemacht
genau identität ist eben genauso
ewigkeiten identität also nicht
gleichheit ist eine ewigkeit denn die
täter also eine welt zum beispiel oder
eine welt in der zwei und 2 5 ist also
irgendwie so inhalten logischer
widerspruch drin oder eine welt in der
es runde quadrate gibt sie immer ganz
schwierig sich seine unmögliche welt
vorzustellen
wir hatten das letzte mal darüber
diskutiert ob eine wild eine mögliche
welt während der die gravitationskraft
nicht nur 81 kilogramm durch sekunde
quadrat sondern 20,5 wäre dieser wert
und hier scheint dass das nicht logisch
widersprüchlich ist und dass es durchaus
möglich wäre
universum in der eben andere
gravitations konstante gilt für die
frage ob gravitations konstante in die
logische im ursprungs ist aber die
scheint kein logisches prinzip zu sein
also es scheint durchaus
widerspruchsfrei denkbar zu sein immer
fazit ist dass die gravitationskraft
eine andere größe hat und das ist
vielleicht gar keine gravitationskraft
gebe
und 8
nur ist es halten widerspruch und
schließt ein quadratisch aus dem sinn
von rund verstehen und in quadratischer
stehen dann darf es nichts kann es nicht
sein dass es sowas gibt die frage hat
immer also eine welt in der so etwas
denkbar wäre wäre logisch
widersprüchliche welt in der so was
erlaubt wäre sei jetzt möchte der sollte
das würde ja ja aber ich glaube nicht
dass leute wie toten definitorischen
frage ist eine logische ist es einfach
so dass wir hier ein widerspruch
herausbekommen wie auch immer wir es
definieren die zwei begriffe vertragen
sich nicht und quadratisch schließen
sich aus und die frage ist immer wie
kann sich eine welt vorstellen so der so
was möglich ist ist immer ganz schwierig
aber vielleicht von der anderen seite
her betrachtet eine andere mögliche welt
wäre wie ich schon sagt in der welt
wurde zahlt hier einmal der stift blickt
andere ganz identischen bedingungen aus
drum und einmal der stift nicht liegt
das ist nicht logisch wieder sportlich
nehmen oder eine welt in der eine person
von ihnen
nachdem sie vom zahnarzt gekommen ist
keine zahnschmerzen hat
doch das kann schon sein
das kann schon sein dass man am zweiten
tag noch ein bisschen warten bis die
wenn die betäubung nachlässt dann kommt
man mal kurzen schmerzen dann am abend
ist es dann vorbei in der regel
er zeigt aber leibnitz eine solche welt
in der es bei einem menschen weniger
zahnschmerz geben
die wäre nicht die bessere welt wenn sie
wäre die schlechtere fällt weil er sagt
die welt in der wir leben so wie sie
faktisch ist das ist die beste aller
möglichen welten die hat gott gewählt
von allen möglichen anderen welten und
sowie die welt jetzt ist so wie wir sie
erleben mit allem leid eben auch mit
allen zahnschmerzen usw
so ist die welt angesichts der
rahmenbedingungen die nicht zu einer
fragen sind die nicht veränderlich sind
die beste bild und das ist doch jetzt
erstmal ein bisschen contra intuitiv das
ist ein problem
das andere problem ist dass wie man eben
gott den man diese drei prädikat
zuspricht allmächtig gütig und
allwissend wie das hier mit der existenz
von leid in der welt an die schreib mir
welt oder mensch denn die ist die
schöpfung wie das damit zusammen hängen
jetzt hatten wir
interessanterweise ähnlich wie diese
drei ist für allmächtig allwissend haben
wir uns drei formen von übel ich will es
gar nicht so viel über das übel sprechen
das böse das habe ich genug einem
anderen seminar gemacht und in anderen
kontexten du wirst gut da nicht
entsprechen
wir müssen dennoch mal alle drei formen
des übels nach leibnitz aufzählen haben
sich noch parat wie er das nennt mal so
mal so und mal umso mal um ist das
schlechte zu üben
wissen sie noch wie man das nennen kann
bei leibnitz drei arten von umbilden
vielleicht haben sie noch alle parat
genau das metaphysische und das nennt
man lateinisch das waren um metaphysik
um das moralische humorale und das mal
um physik ich war gestern vormittag auf
einer tagung über hiob den sie ja alle
kennen das buch hiob im schloss
fürstenried ganz am ende der drei
schloss fürstenried tagung war nur hiob
gewidmet dem bösen im uebel wirklich im
hier ums buch und ich habe da einen
vortrag gehalten habe gesagt diese drei
formen des bösen des übels finden wir
auch bei hiob also wir können leibnitz
auf hiob anwenden und hat eine sehr
bekannte professoren gesagt sie haben
schon recht aber sollten wir nicht bei
hier brauchen zusätzliches mal um ein
führen nämlich bei hier breitet ja nicht
nur körperlich hat ja nicht nur
krankheiten sondern er leidet auch
seelenschmerz als seine kinder sterben
würden sie jetzt den fall dass ein kind
stirbt oder ein naher verwandter von
ihnen würden sie diesen fall als ein
körperliches übel beschreiben dass die
frage wie würden sie dieses übel
beschreiben
sein körperlicher schmerz es ist ja kein
moralisches übel
sie tun ja nichts moralisches oder ihnen
wird ja nichts moralisches angetan
und sie sind vorgesehen
ja sicherlich findet man der tradition
verschiedene reaktionen darauf aber wenn
sie jetzt einfach mal phänomenologische
von dem leid gefühl von den schmerzen
schon wieder was besonders gute wie
fühlt sich denn das an wo denn das weh
wenn ein verwandter von ihnen stirbt
oder ein haustier oder so tut das weh
wie zahnschmerzen oder wird wie vieh
leiden sie darunter
richtig richtig sie haben recht ja
richtig als es dann so eine volk genau
man leidet auch körperlich aber leitete
man denn nur körperlich das hatte
nämlich diese professorinnen gästen
angemerkt ja als man hätte auch einmal
um physikum aber jetzt haben sie ja
schon gesagt seelisch oder sie wollten
auch etwas sand ja genau
genau weil das physikum ist häufig etwas
äußeres als unser körper ist so diese
professoren meinte dann einmal um zügig
um oder wie auch immer also ein
psychisches bleibt das stimmt aber ich
glaube dass es auf derselben ebene ist
wie diesmal um physik um das ist etwas
was uns als individuum schmerz bereitet
das also immer weltlicher schmerz auch
wenn er ihnen psychisch ließen man
könnte das also noch ins äußere ins
innere unterscheiden
malo moral ist also wenn ich jemandem
etwas tue einmal um physikum zufüge sei
es jetzt ein innerliches oder ein
äußerliches ich kann jemanden auch
kranken so dass der körper intakt ist
ich kann jemanden beleidigen
dann ist dieser mensch diese person
innerlich verletzt
mal um psychisch kommen oder wie man es
nennen möchte und in dem ich so etwas
tue und zwar willentlich begehe ich
einmal um moral
dann habe ich ein moralisches übel und
die welt gesetzt
und jetzt ist die frage wie vertragen
sich diese drei formen des übels auch
wenn man nicht mal metaphysik und
diskutiert was ist das wir kommen da
noch mal darauf zu sprechen genau heute
[Musik]
okay okay sie würde sagen ein kübel war
es nicht in der hand des menschen liegt
ja das wäre eine metaphysik um ist eine
möglichkeit leibnitz meint jetzt
allerdings etwas anderes darunter sie ja
hier
nicht nur weniger leisten
wo es machen wir identität
als ich sagen ist es auch eine
begründung also das folgt daraus und das
volk auch daraus also das ist nicht auf
derselben ebene das mal um physikum
metaphysik um existiert nicht auf
derselben ebene wie das mal um moral und
dass man ihm physikum so dass es
irgendeinen begründung zusammenhang als
ich mache zehn mal so ein strick
dazwischen könnte sagen das ist der
grund davon oder ist die metaebene oder
so das hatte logisches seite wie sie
richtig zeigen also der grund für die
existenz dieser maler und sie haben auch
schon angewiesen ist es also effekt mit
der endlichkeit zusammen
die endlichkeit der geschöpfe wie als
geschöpfe nach leibnitz sind
notwendigerweise endlich weil wenn wir
nicht endlich wehren bot uns so nicht
hätte schaffen können
gott muss indem er allmächtig ist auch
schützen er muss eine schöpfung die welt
bringen nur kann diese schöpfung nicht
wie er sein er kann sich nicht
reproduzieren sind die schöpfung muss
notwendigerweise beschränkt sein
sie muss endlich sein und aus dieser
ähnlichkeit folgt dann ist sich mit
notwendigkeit vielleicht aber zumindest
die möglichkeit nach dass es eben auch
solche sachen gibt
richtig oder punkt also das ist eine
gute frage aber zumindest waren adam und
eva immer die frage wo man die freiheit
ansetzt im sündenfall
aber sie waren offensichtlich frei denn
beide konnten vom baum der erkenntnis
essen im sündenfall muss man
unterscheiden zwischen dem pre
japanischen zustand der lapsus ist der
sündenfall lapsus dem pre japanischen
das ist dem vorstand des sündenfalls vor
dem sündenfall und dem post klaps
arischen und das ist eine gute frage
jetzt haben wir so wenn man so will
könnte man sagen
adam und eva haben einmal um morales
begangen im sündenfall
ich kann man die diskussion schon also
indem sie sich von der schlange haben
überreden lassen verführen lassen und
gegen gottes gebot gehandelt haben
haben sie einmal um morales begangen sie
haben gottes sind haben gebot gottes
gebot übertreten
das ist ja klar und aus diesem moral das
sieht man sehr schön im sündenfall folgt
dann das marum physikum nachdem adam und
eva vom baum der erkenntnis gegessen
haben was passiert mit ihnen dann was
machen sie dann ja
genau richtig genau und was muss die
frau machen kinder gebären unter
schmerzen und der man muss hart arbeiten
im schweiße seines angesichts eines mal
um physik um das ist eine folge des
marler moral könnte man sagen dass mal
um physik und ist aber dann post larisch
als immer die frage ist diese also wenig
sozietät ist diesmal moral halle vom
baum der erkenntnis zu essen obwohl man
es nicht darf fällt das jetzt in den pre
japanischen zustand oder ein postler
page
es ist der abschluss an sich zwar orale
konzipiert mit dem lapsus
das ist der sündenfall als solcher und
haben es schon in der schöpfung als adam
und eva sind in dem moment wo sie das
mal moral begeben werden sie auch
endlich aber die tatsache dass sie es
begehen können zeigt dass ich schon
endlich sind weil sie das mal moral
vollbringen können also ist ganz
interessant das malz interpretieren
woher kommt der grund dass sich dafür
entscheiden dass sie das mal einem orale
begehen obwohl sie doch eigentlich die
sind natürlich nicht wie gott aber wenn
sie vom baum des lebens noch gegessen
hätten ja dann wäre es problematisch
geworden deswegen verwirrt ja auch gott
ihnen den zutritt zum paradies weil sie
jetzt schon die erkenntnis haben und wie
gott sind sagte auch die schlange werde
sein wie gott sie haben also die
erkenntnis von gut und böse das ist ja
auch ein göttliches prädikat aber sie
dürfen nicht vom baum des lebens essen
weil sonst würden sie noch unsterblich
werden nachdem zuvor
deswegen wird ihnen ja auch der zutritt
verwehrt zurückzugehen ins paradies weil
sie jetzt schon göttliche eigenschaften
haben durch die erkenntnis des konnten
böse aber ich würde sagen dass sie eben
vom baum bekenntnis essen das sie einmal
um moral begehen zeigt dass sie endlich
sind darin setzen sie sich endlich und
daraus folgt unmittelbar das mal um
physikum
und auch wenn sie mal genauer hinschauen
auch die scham dass sich plötzlich
schämen für ihre nacktheit
das ist auch eine phänomenologische
zeichen ihrer endlichkeit kann also
alles schon sehr guter sehe aber sind
gute frage aber wie gesagt sie müssten
auch vom baum des lebens essen und
unsterblich zu sein und wie gott zu sein
und das machen sie nicht dürfen sie
mussten ja sind gute frage sie haben
nicht vom baum des lebens gegessen aber
jedenfalls waren sie nicht ja sie waren
jedenfalls nicht
sie hatten das ist jetzt auch nicht ganz
genau vielleicht weiß jemand von ihm
besser also ob sie jetzt wirklich
unsterblich waren jedenfalls waren sie
weil sie irgendwie selig sie mussten
jetzt nicht hart arbeiten sie hatten
jedenfalls nicht vom baum der erkenntnis
gegessen er vom baum des lebens gegessen
und das wäre ja das unsterblich die
unsterblichkeit
also dieser zustand vor dem sündenfall
hinsichtlich der unendlichkeit ist eine
ganz spannende frage
das goldene zeitalter pin-codes zeiten
wo wir bestimmt sind und keine
existenzsorgen haben gebot zu
witzigerweise dann klagten später sagen
dass ich seinen start der schweine
es gibt keine arbeit keine anstrengung
wert ist es immer ein genauer ins dann
ist hier alles so echt sich und wer das
aus der sicht auch einmal die vorteile
für sorten keine freiheit letztendlich
in diesem sinne kann individualität
nicht menschlich oder punkte
mit der endlichkeit und auch eben
endlich auch endlich ist
gute frage
richtig richtig
ja das ist also ein recht großes thema
woher kommt wenn man könnte ja häufig
sagen dass man um physikum ist mir
folgende strafe diesmal um moral
das folgt auf das manu moran wird häufig
in solchen begründung verhältnissen
gesagt man physikum krankheiten sind
strafe für begangenes übel wurde häufig
gemacht wird heute immer noch gemacht
teilweise deswegen krank geworden weil
du was böses getan hast natürlich ein
höchst problematischer schluss weil es
im umkehrschluss auch so sein kann dass
jemand der nur gutes getan hat wie hiob
oder jemand anderes das der trotzdem
nicht glücklich wird also dissens ist es
hoch problematisch aber die frage warum
die tiere leiden müssen wo sie doch gar
nicht einmal um moral in der lage sind
das dann abhängigkeit bestehen könnte
die iss wird diskutiert das ist ein
riesenproblem würde aber eben in des
seminares böse er einfach fallen ich
wollte noch einen punkt mehr
berücksichtigen und zwar der das vor dem
sündenfall eigentlich gar nicht der
begriff des google bösen angewendet
werden konnte
da gab es diese unterscheidung nicht
weil sie nicht vom baum der erkenntnis
gegessen haben also diese ganze
unterscheidung die wir hier haben die
ist vor dem sündenfall noch gar nicht
thematisch als diese ganzen der
scheidung scheint mir ersten spiel zu
kommen als der baum der erkenntnis in
den blick gerät der star die
unterscheidungen sichtbar werden oder
essen
so interpretiere ich jedenfalls für sie
war das kein thema sie hatten keine
begriffe von gut und böse
sie waren irgendwie waren könnte man
sagen und das bringt mich jetzt zum
weiteren denker den wir in der zweiten
hälfte dieses seminares behandelt werden
nämlich russo presse spricht von den
naturzustand den naturzustand ist
ungefähr dieser zustand dieser player
preller psychische zustand
er wusste und das ist der zustand der
vor allem vom baum der erkenntnis
gegessen wurde
bevor der sündenfall stattgefunden hat
einen zustand in dem gut und böse noch
keine rolle spielen
an ihnen differenz zustand von dem
airbus so sagt das war einigen
glückseliger zustand würde jetzt nicht
sagen dass er gut war vielleicht weil
sie sagen da waren bestimmte
eigenschaften vorhanden die im gegensatz
zur moderne schützenswert sind
man kann dieses unfall geschichte mit
blick auf das gute sehr sehr gut auf
andere philosophen anwenden wie zb
person wenn es um seine
entwicklungsgeschichte geht als jemand
fragen möchte woher kommt das böse das
böse und woher das gute oder soll man
das nicht gut wenn man häufig davon
ausgeht es begann alles mit dem guten
und dann gab es eine verfalls geschichte
wir begannen im guten das war alles okay
un-angaben gab es irgendwie eine
katastrophe da hat jemand ein apfel
gegessen und warum zur kenntnis und dann
kam das böse in die welt
und so ähnlich sieht es auch so eine
verfalls geschichte des gutes steht am
anfang und die weiter die geschichte
voranschreitet umso mehr entfernt sich
die schöpfung von diesen guten und
kleiner bezugspunkt zur letzten sitzung
sehen und sich dann noch an diese drei
modelle die ich ihnen darum geschickt
hatte haben sie diese zusammenfassung
bekommen diese drei modelle wie man sich
das verhältnis von gut und böse
vorstellen kann
das hängt natürlich damit auch zusammen
und man sich das vorstellt jetzt hatten
sie sich glaube ich noch gemeldet da die
schlange ist eine gute frage
wirkliche rolle spielt gibt es die frage
ist die optisch lange als ich
interpretiere die schlange als als mal
um mit als manu metaphysik und so
interpretiere ich die [ __ ]
die schlange ist kein gegenstand in der
welt ist die schlange ist eine
rahmenbedingung ja hier so ein prinzip
diesem prinzip viele interpretieren die
schlange als teufel
das muss man nicht machen also schlange
schlange hat sowas schlinge dass der
teufel wird häufig auch so ein bisschen
als drache dargestellt also manche sagen
die schlange ist sei der teufel muss
aber nicht sein aber natürlich kann man
sich fragen
die schlange ist doch nicht das gute ist
darüber dass böse wie kann es denn
bietet schon vor dem sündenfall schon
das böse irgendwie der welt sein würde
ich halt sagen es so wie schlange ist
nicht dass meine moral nicht dass man um
physik und dieses mal metaphysik um
irgendwie da klingt die endlichkeit des
menschen schon an
obwohl er noch gar nicht vom baum der
erkenntnis gegessen hat also ich würde
sagen die schlange ist diesmal im
zeichen des manometer physikum
aber stimmt natürlich
ist ein 2
ja man kann das aber gut mit gottes
allmacht verbinden
man kann sagen die schlange ist sich das
gegen prinzip zu gott der teufel soll
wenn man das so tut wie ich gerade
versucht habe wenn man sagt die schlange
ist das mahnung mit h physikum also
nicht den gegenstand zum prinzip der
rahmenbedingungen dann passt das mal mit
der physik um wieder mit gottes allmacht
zusammen oder alte weil ihr kommilitone
gesagt hatten wir hier gleich auch
anhand des textes sehen werden
gott notwendigerweise insofern er eine
schöpfung überhaupt die welt setzte
dieses mal mit der physik zu lassen
musste das geht gar nicht anders muss
notwendigerweise mit der schöpfung
einhergehen mit der für die kunst steht
im widerspruch zur gültigkeit der karte
in den hals
wir nehmen uns jemand wirklich glücklich
der also für die vor demnach hätten sie
die gefährte und kann alle und coachings
und die alttestamentarische über es ist
ebenfalls ein sehr moralisches
gottesbild ein see moralisches
gottesbilder aber auch moralisch war
eben die zehn gebote schon so eine
absolute moralische autorität verfolgung
und dahinter mit dieser güte mit dieser
strengen gesetzlichkeit moralität ich
finde schon dass diese strenge die
moralische gesetzlichkeit und all good
ich kaid al goethe zusammen passt
irgendwie immer die frage was zu
unterallgäuer zu verstehen ist das
geschieht natürlich viel leid im alten
testament mehr als im 9
aber ja das ist jetzt ein ex ethische
frage ich denke nach leibnitz wäre das
möglich auch mit dem alten testament zu
vereinbaren
sie versuchen die dahin fühlt das ist ja
kein faktum einfach so sondern das
ergebnis der führung eines erwarten
ziehen
und das mit dabei ist dass ich nicht
mehr aktive dass das spiel zum
allmächtigen strengeren war alles schön
also auch einen also leibnitz hat
natürlich kein geht es rein christliche
gottesbild im auge sind das ist ein
philosophischer gottesbegriff den er hat
das ist ein sehr abstrakter
gottesbegriff und hinsichtlich dieser
frage nach all gültigkeit und eine
mächtigkeit da kann man noch drauf
bleibt es unterscheidet nämlich zwischen
dem verstand und dem willen gottes
das sind zwei prinzipien in gott aus der
konfiguration dieser zwei prinzipien
kann beides letztendlich an güte und an
mächtigkeit bewahrt werden
also dass da kommen noch drauf es ist
jedenfalls sehr sehr kompliziert bleibt
nutzern ganz hinten noch eine frage
ansonsten bekommen
genau also
[Musik]
das ist
also einmal in den zehn geboten du
sollst nicht und du sollst nicht und so
weiter und daneben auch noch in der im
guiness also genesis genesis 3 wo eben
verboten wird vom baum bekenntnis zu
essen und in dem darf verboten wird
du sollst nicht du darfst nicht müsste
mal genau und hebräischen text schauen
was da steht aber jedenfalls ein verbot
daraus kann man schließen dass das wesen
es unter umständen täterin es nicht
geboten nicht verboten wäre
und daraus folgt guter hinweis das ist
schon da letztendlich endlich ist das da
schon dieses mal metaphysik um an
angelegt ist aus der tatsache dieses
verbots ein unendliches wesen braucht
nichts verboten zu bekommen für das das
würde es nicht machen
ein guter hinweis also das wäre so ein
grund dafür zusagen auf ihre frage dass
eben schon im prälat arischen zustand
dieses verbot da ist und wie mir scheint
wird es eben dieses mal metaphysik um
besonders gut durch die schlange
symbolisiert die schlange wäre so eine
art gravitationskraft eine
verführungskraft die uns von der rechten
bahn so ablenkt wie ein magnet wie so
ein polo minuspol der uns irgendwie
anzieht wo in dem wir uns davon anziehen
lassen zeigen wir dass wir unter dieses
motto metaphysik umfallen weil wir so
ein hang dazu habe so eine
wir lassen uns anziehen wir sind
magnetisch magnetisiert bahr wiesen
polarisiert basis bestehen aus eisen wir
können angezogen
so könnte man sich das vorstellen
vielleicht
mögliche welt
diese option ist
genauso wie wir werden es hier sehen wie
gottes all mächtigkeiten in seiner güte
zusammenhängt angesichts des bösen das
sagt leiteritz interessante sachen also
er sagt jetzt hier wenn es somit das ist
jetzt sehr provokativ das ist wirklich
könnte man auch sagen das ist zynisch
was natürlich leid und sich ziemlich
meint aber prima fazit könnte man sagen
wenn es somit das geringste übel dass in
der welt eintrifft fehlt hält wie er es
nicht mehr diese welt die alles in allem
von dem sie auswählen den schöpfer als
die beste befunden worden ist so ist es
wir dürfen keine sekunde weniger
zahnschmerzen dieser welt schulden das
wäre schlecht wenn es endlich müssten
jetzt eigentlich ein paar beispiele zwar
kann man sich selten ohne sünden ohne
unglück vorstellen und so etwas daraus
machen wie die romane von utopien aber
diese welten würden im übrigen der
unsrigen erheblich nachstehen wissen
außerdem das oft ein übel an gut bewirkt
welches ohne dieses übel nicht
eingetroffen wäre oft haben sogar zwei
über ein großes gut zufolge also er sagt
jetzt endlich die menschen können gar
nicht wissen in welchem kontext ein
einzelnes übel steht die menschen
betrachten das übel immer isoliert
dieses übel dieses übel dieses sie sehen
aber nicht den zusammenhang in dem das
übel steht und das übersteht nicht einen
destruktiven zusammenhang seien
letztendlich vergleich mit zumindest
einem konstruktiven zusammenhang gut
zahnschmerzen kann man doch mal beim
zahnschmerz bleiben immerhin ist doch
gut dass wir zahnschmerzen haben wir
wenn wir es nicht hätten wüssten wir
nicht dass wir zum zahnarzt gehen müssen
so toll der zahnschmerzen schwert ich
mein so kann lydia kommentieren der zahn
schmerzt ist ein gutes zeichen
eigentlich demant und die sind ganz
warnsignal des körpers
es kann weiter fragen warum bin ich denn
überhaupt so ausgestattet dass sich
zahnschmerzen haben kann
könnte ich nicht auch so genau so sein
ich bin nur ohne schmerzempfindung oder
so gut an sagt bleibt uns ja aber gut du
bist halt immer ein ähnliches wesen und
irgendwas musste doch zeigen wenn da was
nicht stimmt dann kann man weiterfahren
wie aber könnte ich nicht so gebaut sein
dass immer alles stimmt dass ich mir
irgendwie in die gefahr krank zu werden
und zeigt bleibt eben nein das geht
nicht weil mahlow metaphysik um menschen
müssen nur weniger weiß als geschöpf
kenntlich sein
es geht nicht anders sonst wären sie ja
wie gott und das lässt sich logisch
nicht denken dass gott einen anderen
gott schafft sich selbst entgegensetzt
das geht nicht wenn er etwas schöpft
dann nur etwas ähnliches frage setzt die
dann die ja wäre es nicht besser wenn
gott überhaupt keine schöpfung
geschaffen hätte das hat das sagt dann
leibnitz offensichtlich nein zu gottes
allgäu gehört notwendigerweise dass
erschöpfen musste eine schöpfung
schaffen musste die welt setzen musste
jetzt wäre nicht als gültig und
allmächtig als in der allmacht gottes
zeigt sich dass er gerade schöpft
endlich ist halt tja müssen wir weiter
lesen etwas saures schafs oder bitteres
gefällt oft besser als zucker ist zucker
das gute kann man sich jetzt frage
zucker es doch nicht gesund zucker ist
doch diabetes und so der schatten des
die farbe stärker hervortreten und
selbst eine dissonanz am rechten platz
geht die harmonie seiten seien begriffe
hinabzustürzen sollen unseren schrecken
versetzen trauer spiele sollen uns bis
zu trennen ergreifen kostet man die
gesundheit aus und dank man gott dafür
wie man niemals krank gewesen ist und
muss nicht meistens ein kleineres übel
das gefühl gute fühlbarer sozusagen
größer werden lassen welches argument
liegt jetzt ihr zugrunde welche funktion
hat sie das böse das schlecht
genau zum kontrast kontrastieren
die theorie
auswertet es arbeiten und handlungen zu
beobachten und für das gute der seite
geboten entscheiden können wir könnten
sie für gott entscheiden
es sind halt nur bei spielen
sehr schön also
das wahrnehmen des bösen
das sind gute zahlen müssen
ja also das ist ein häufiges beispiel
der philosophie das was aktion
kontrasten kontrast folie gut und böse
eben nur im gegensätzlichkeit
kontrastierend natürlich kann man sich
dann fragen wird an das gute nicht
gewertet wenn man es nur im kontrast zum
bösen überhaupt sichtbar werden lassen
kann was das gut wie ich auch ohne das
böse wie erkennbar sein oder bemerkbar
sein
da sitzt also dem scheidet zum bisschen
polaris modell zugrunde zu liegen wie
mir scheint sie erinnern sich noch nicht
drei modelle die wir da hatten
das scheint jetzt ihr nicht dieses
dieses aktuelle modell zu sein wo hier
null ist null ist ja nichts
das scheint ihr so ein polaris zahlen
dass man es an etwas misst
ja hier ist doch so ein argument für die
zeile so verliert sich der bekannte teil
des universums verglichen mit dem
unbekannten den wir dann noch annehmen
müssen beinahe nichts und alle übel die
man uns entgegenhalten kann haben nur
geltung bezogen auf dieses beinahe
nichts muss man da nicht sagen dass alle
übel verglichen mit den gütern dieser
welt auch ein beinahe nichts sind was
setzt das argument hier
und zwar wie genau wie versuchte jetzt
das böse zu relativieren ist eine
relativierung denke ich kann man sagen
das müssen
haben sie ein vergleich mit was kann man
das vergleichen dieses dieses übel hier
aus dieser perspektive
könnte man so sagen genau man könnte
auch so sie kennen doch diese assen
toten so na also hier irgendwie so sind
endlich hier
und irgendwo hier in der unendlichkeit
geht ja auch eine asyl tote wie gegen
null geht gegen null ms sie kennen es
lima ist also auf lange sicht in
unendlicher sich cent geht es gegen null
und wenn das universum unendlich ist
immens wichtig um endlich ist dann geht
jedes leid jetzt endlich gegen null
dieser welt wenn sie dieses universum
noch größer noch größer noch größer
machen
geht es doch schon fast gegen null ist
doch fast schon zum limes die da drinnen
liegt
würde es würde ist sicherlich immer noch
sagen was für ein so fischer sicher
würde sagen gut
die menschheit kann mit sich machen was
sie will aber sie ist halt nur so ein
kleiner planet und bleibt kleiner
planeten herum schwirrt irgendwie so
eine galaxie so einer unter vielen
wenn wir alle galaxien alle supernovae
alles zusammen nehmen dann ist die erde
was auch immer sich darauf abspielt
völlig unbedeutend natürlich wird das
niemanden befriedigen der jetzt davon
betroffen ist von diesem leid da kann
man schon sagen das ist aber eine art
wie soll ich sagen arg abgehobene
perspektive auf das leid gibt es ja auch
andere stellen der bibel und so die eben
gerade das was jetzt hier betont wurde
dieses individuelle leid besonders stark
machen wenn wir hier ist es ja auch so
die hier um geschichte ist ja auch so
da steckt ja auch das steht auch das
individuelle ist individuum mit seinem
leid total im zentrum neuen testament
genauso oder man zieht er das leibnitz
so wie es mir jedenfalls scheint nicht
mehr jetzt wirklich im christlichen
sinne hier argumentiert hat das
natürlich im hintergrund die christliche
theologie aber es scheint doch ein sehr
philosophischen begriff davon seien
logischen begriff metaphysischen beklagt
dass relativierung charmaine chan gab es
eine meldung und auch jemand was zu
diesem argument sagen ja jetzt kommt
glaube ich das entscheidende was jetzt
für das manometer physik und besonders
wichtig ist jetzt sagte nämlich hier die
alten halle die antiken verlegten die
ursache des bösen in die materie
diese für uns schaffen und von gott
unabhängig
aber wo finden wir die wir alles sein
von gott her leiten die quelle des bösen
beantworten dann muss sie in der idealen
natur des geschöpfes aufsuchen soweit
diese natur in den ewigen wahrheiten des
göttlichen verstandes unabhängig von
seinen willen enthalten ist
es gibt nämlich in der kreatur eine
ursprüngliche unvollkommenheit vor aller
sünde weil begrenzt soll zum wesen der
kreatur gilt daher kann sie nicht alles
wissen die täuschen und andere fehler
beginnen
das ist jetzt glaube ich das ganz
entscheidende zitat das ist jetzt erst
mal sehr schwierig wie argumentiert
jetzt leibnitz für die notwendigkeit des
übels und zumindest die notwendigkeit
dieser demo wie möglich die notwendige
möglichkeit so etwas so dieser übel also
wohl ist die ursache des bösen nicht zu
finden nach leibnitz
eben nicht
ich nehme
dass sich daraus ein politikum
wie lange das
nicht richtig dazu
[Musik]
vieles mehr
es ist aus dem bestmöglichen
man sollte vielleicht noch hinzufügen
also bleibt sagt dass die ursache des
bösen ist nicht in der materie zu finden
das haben viele antiken gesagt als bei
platon geht sind diese richtung
pro team geht es in diese richtung alle
platonischen modelle die sagen sie
kennen alle haben wir auch hier
behandelt zugleich haben uns gefragt wo
ist jetzt bitteschön das böse zu finden
in diesem höhe gleichnis ganz unten
natürlich in der welt ganz unten im
schatten so ganz rund
das ist da ist es böse proteinen
antreten dieser richtung einem
philosophen zu sagen denn das böse ist
die materie möglich das ist nicht das
ideal ist es nicht die welt der ideen in
denen das böse besteht und das ist jetzt
ein ganz wichtiger unterschied zu
plaudern bleibt sagt der grund des bösen
liegt in der materie also ganz punkten
im höhlengleichnis sondern irgendwie
ganz oben in den ideen nämlich die
quelle des bösen dritte zeile antworten
man muss sie in der idealen natur der
ideale natur des geschöpfes aufsuchen
soweit diese natur in den ewigen
wahrheiten des göttlichen verstandes und
das sind die ideen nach platon
unabhängig von seinem willen enthalten
ist
vollkommene um wendung des grundes
büßten jetzt rede ich schon wieder über
das böse in die ganze zeit stabil
also nicht ganz unten seien ganz oben
und das sieht man jetzt diesen
unterschied zu platon platon hat eben
nicht dieses hat dieses schöpfungs
modell was leibnitz hat bleibt sagt die
schöpfung ist jetzt nicht nur so ein
abglanz oder so wir sind nicht einfach
so ein abglanz des die idee des guten
sondern die idee des guten wird vielmehr
zusammengebunden bei leibnitz mit der
konkreten existenz sie kennen ja auch
die moderne nomaden lehre auch schon mal
gehört bestimmte sind raten also
verleitet es ist wohl so dass das hotel
und das ist glaube dass entscheiden ist
es gute immer auch im schlechten
enthalten ist das gute wird es sehr
konkret gedacht und wir finden die
spuren des guten nämlich das ideale
göttlichen verstandes in allem endlich
also alles endlich ist nicht nur
irgendwie privat eve das ist jetzt nicht
so ein aktuelles prinzip dass man sagt
hier dass das böse das ist halt
irgendwie bei null so und je weiter wir
runter kommen desto mehr materie das zu
mir nichts böses haben wir uns hier oben
sind ideen sondern wenn ich es recht zäh
sagt leibnitz dass wir im ländlichen im
individuellen immer die spuren der
schöpfung und letztendlich auch gottes
sehen die letztendlich zurückzuführen
sind auf seinen verstand er gottes
verstand die logik der schöpfung könnte
man sagen
die logik der schöpfung erhält
notwendigerweise die forderung dass das
was geschäft ist endlich ist das damit
eben auch unter bestimmten umständen mal
um mal ein physiker moralist entstehen
können
es ist aber auch nicht anders
insofern ist auf dem plakat und
installation der disposition die
realität der ideen gehen und er das ist
ja nicht falsch liegen
mit offen aber seine spätere sie den
kinos da ist der welt in stoff der die
millionärin ähnliche der alten ideen mit
der materie so zusammen koppelt die
beste aller möglichen hälfte zu
begleiten
der master auch mit mit allen lösungen
übeln die einfach in der natur der sache
dann mit gegeben aber im ständigen
hinblick auf das gute auf die idee doch
voll mit der materie
wirklich aber die man aber der grund der
endlichkeit auch nach diesem bild wäre
ja die vermischung mit materien und das
ist beileibe nicht mehr so super
leibnitz ist der grund des bösen die
logik der schöpfung ist die ideale
verstandes logik der schöpfung und sie
in gottes verstand wenn ich es recht
verstehen ist sondern eingehen prägt die
notwendigkeit der endlichkeit der
schöpfer wende schöpfung da ist muss sie
endlich sein aus logischen gründen und
nicht weiter so ein materielles prinzip
ist zum polaris modell also leibnitz hat
kein wie mir scheint kein aktuelles
modell von gut und böse und auch kein
polaris modell das hier so dass dunkle
gibt hier das gefälle das gute und es
geht um mischungsverhältnisse sondern
das böse ist eine rein logische sache
das schlechte das aus der logik der
stadt verfolgt und die lob der schöpfung
ist eben nach leibnitz der verstand
göttliche verstand und jetzt kommt eben
noch der wille endspielen der wille und
der wille gottes der betrifft die alt
ich die hütte gottes also man muss man
kann jetzt nach leibnitz die erhöhte
gottes waren obwohl der verstand vorgibt
dass es notwendigerweise ähnlichkeit
geben muss dieses zusammenspiel von
wille und verstand können wir nach
leibnitz beide prädikate all
mächtigkeiten aller güte aufrecht
erhalten wir müssen jetzt noch genauer
schauen wir das macht jedenfalls will
der wille nach leibnitz gottes willen
nach leibnitz immer nur das gute und das
will ich aber letztendlich auch noch an
die vorgaben des verstandes gebunden und
in diesem zusammenspiel einiger einigen
sich sozusagen diese vermögen auf die
beste aller möglichen welten
das ist diese welt geht dem dem prinzip
des verstandes das ist die all
mächtigkeit die eben fordert es muss
endlich seine schöpfung und die erhöhte
die dann den logischen kompromiss der
wille liefert das ist eben dann eine die
bestmögliche einrichtung angesichts
dieser ähnlichkeit ist dass wir eben
beide prädikate nachlass noch
rechtfertigen können
ich habe ich über sie denken
er hat die simona denn er hat diese
monaten lehre dass es noch mal das sind
dann die individuellen existenzen die
spiegel des gesamten universums sind ja
das ist dann auch mal andere punkt aber
es ist sind letztendlich geht doch von
von einer endlichen schöpfung aus diese
serie ist ja noch mal oder spezial
verlieren
ja also die die seelen der ist dann
nochmal spezifikum davon aber wenn es
jetzt nur darum geht dass man sagt wie
kommt das leid in der welt zustande das
ist leben unbestritten das kann auch mit
einer seele einher gehen dann sagt
bleibt nichts dieses faktum des leids
dessen notwendigerweise wieder schöpfung
einhergeht das erklärt sich daraus dass
die schöpfung endlich sein muss
hast du s
genau dass man sagen würde
das sagt zum beispiel krank wie die idee
des höchsten gutes kann sagt er
wenn der gerechte oder der moralisch
gute in der wirklichen welt in der
irdischen existenz unheil erfahren hat
mal um physik um das ist ja die
glückseligkeit
das ist letztendlich das betrifft nach
aristoteles also wenn man seinen
bohrungen physikum wohnung für sie kommt
das betrifft ein bisschen die
glückseligkeit die harmonia wobei die
harmonia bei aristoteles auch schwach
normativ ist wie mir scheint dass dann
auch das bonner moral drin ist also das
wäre dann so eine kantige perspektive
das höchste gut ist dass man sagen muss
dieses im irdischen leben erfahrene leid
muss ausgeglichen werden durch eine
belohnung nach dem tod
und da dadurch daraus folgt nach kant in
praktischer hinsicht die notwendigkeit
der unsterblichkeit der seele
das sind also noch andere fragen die
ausgleichend sind kann muss dieses
postulat denken der proposition ali-t
proportionalität von moralität und
glückseligkeit das ist das höchste gut
also jemand der moralisch ist er muss
das fordert die vernunft nach kann auch
irgendwie belohnt werden dafür muss wenn
wir auch glückselig sein das ist
eigentlich ein widerspruch der vernunft
die ja das gute befiehlt dass sie uns
das gute befiehlt dann aber nicht sorge
dafür trägt dass wir wenn wir das gute
tun auch glückselig werden das kann sagt
kann eigentlich nicht nur von uns
gebieten das wäre keine gute vernunft
wenn sie uns gebieten würde tue das gute
und nicht zugleich als auch noch
versprechen würde dass wir wenn wir das
gute tun aber noch glückselig werden das
ist also die kantige perspektive und
damit letztendlich kann zu dieses dieses
ideale konstrukt und leibnitz scheint
mit dieses ideale künstler eben mehr aus
der logik der schöpfung heraus zu
erklären
er braucht nicht diese postulaten wäre
bekannt weil er sagt das gute ist schon
in dieser welt das ist die beste
einrichtung angesichts der
rahmenbedingungen die gott ausmachen die
gott gar nicht zur verfügung zur
disposition stehen gott kann gar keine
andere an andere welt schaffen
man muss diese welt so wie sie es
schaffen aus seiner idealen natur heraus
angesichts dieser rahmenbedingungen aus
der logik erschöpfung könnte man zu
haben das hat nicht so sehr diese
langfristige perspektive einer
ausgleichenden gerechtigkeit wie sie
kann in seiner postulaten berater zwar
noch zwei meldungen vorne und glaube ich
ganz hinten ja
ideale natur des geschöpfes das ist
jetzt natürlich ein bisschen provokativ
mal wieso soll das geschäft eine ideale
natur haben wenn es doch
notwendigerweise dass man um morales
mahnung physikum mit sich bringt muss er
ist dann diese natur noch ideal
das ist die frage ich glaube egal da
wird es nicht so verstanden werden dass
ist genau jetzt nicht nutzen das ist die
logische logisch genauso würdig sind die
logische notwendige natur ist und dass
sie daran dass wirklich alle betonten
also indem er sagt die ideale natur
ideal ist jetzt haben wir nicht im sinne
von gut zu verstehen aber eben auch
nicht im sinne von schlecht oder böse
also die ideale natur die begrenzung die
zum wesen der kreatur gehört die es
erstmal natürlich indifferent von
beurteilung wie gut und böse und
schlecht
es ist einfach die logische folge der
schöpfung schöpfung muss endlich sein
und das ist jetzt erst mal noch vor
diese unterscheidung von gut und
schlecht gute böse er technisch sehr gut
weil es ist ja die schöpfung wir müssen
ja froh sein dass überhaupt existieren
wir könnten ja auch nicht existieren
wenn die welt in der wir existieren sagt
bleibt es ist immer noch eine bessere
welt also wir werden der nicht
existieren absackt schopenhauer genau
das gegenteil wir leben der
schlechtesten aller möglichen welten
wird ja viel besser wenn wir nicht leben
legen nichts wissen pessimismus
also schopenhauers er meint es ihm ist
er und leibnitz ein sehr großer optimist
zwar glaube ich ganz hinten noch eine
meldung
ja
genau das ist eine gute frage bleibt
sagt in einer anderen stelle dass wir
uns gott nicht vorstellen dürfen als ein
despoten der willkürlich einfach so welt
so nach lust und laune sondern bleibt
sagt dass gott in seinen handlungen an
die vorgabe der vernunft gebunden ist
er würde aber sagen dass eben freiheit
und da ist er auf einer linie von kant
dass freiheit eben nicht irgendeine
willkürliche wahl ist so eine wahl wie
es einmal beliebt so eine wahl nach
prinzipien nach den prinzipien des guten
und die prinzipien des guten sind nach
leibnitz die prinzipien der vernunft der
ordnung und das wäre so ein rationaler
autonomie gott handelt deswegen frei
weil er sich durch die von uns selbst
bestimmt sind bestimmt sich rational und
rationales handeln ist freies handel
sagt bleibt nutzen
das wäre so seine antwort also es ist
eine gewisse notwendigkeit die
notwendige ausrichtung an der vernunft
in dem gott der verfolgt im handel der
frei vernunft turnusgemäß handeln ist
freiheit nach leibnitz höchste freiheit
ist für ihn dann auch letztendlich
notwendigkeit einer gewissen
genau genau oder die entscheidung zum
bösen folgen nicht dem von uns
gedruckter wieder setzen wir uns im jahr
geraten
also das hat bleibt es dann tendenziell
dass das böse handeln und da hat er dann
seine privat ions theoretische haben
sich dass das eine trägheit ist dass das
eine widerständigkeit ist die dem guten
entgegensteht
da zeigt sich unser mahlow metaphysik um
das ist träge ist dass es sich nicht so
leicht auf das gute führen lässt wir
haben da ich habe da auch noch so ein
paar stellen dazu die wir lesen können
also jedoch mal eine zusatz oder
verletzung sein es gibt nämlich in der
kreatur eine ursprünglich
unvollkommenheit vor aller sünde bei
begrenzung zum wesen die kreatur gehört
daher kann sie nicht alles wissen sie
ist nicht allwissend ich kann sich
täuschen und andere fehler begehen also
diese prädikate hier die treffen eben
auf den menschen alle nicht zu alle als
schöpfung ähnliches
und jetzt kommt die antwort auf ihre
frage sagte gott ist verstand und die
notwendigkeit dh die wesentliche natur
natur der dinge soweit sie in ewigen
wahrheiten besteht ist gegenstand des
verstandes
aber dieser gegenstand ist ein innerer
und findet sich im göttlichen verstanden
und hier findet sich die ursprüngliche
form des guten aber auch der ursprung
des bösen die region die ewigen
wahrheiten gilt es an die stelle der
materie zu setzen wenn man den grill
aller dinge sucht diese region ist um es
so auszudrücken der ideal grund des
bösen wie des kunden also dass mahle
metaphysik um ist jetzt nichts
schlechtes sondern immer auch gut weil
es eben die schöpfung ist der grund der
schützen
es ist die schattenseite der schöpfung
sag ich mal erschöpfung kriegen wir eben
nur als endlich erschöpfung aber weil es
eben schöpfung ist dies zugleich gut die
welt in der wir als geschöpfe existieren
ist nach leibnitz besser als eine welt
in der wir nicht existieren
deswegen es ist so die zweischneidigkeit
der existenz haben wir dürfen eben das
manometer physikum nicht nur als böse
betracht dafür habe ich auch gestern
argumentiert in meinem vortrag über hier
das hier letztendlich auch sich mit den
problemen der der endlichkeit befasst
nicht nur des körperlichen leiter des
physischen bereits und deswegen eben
dieses leid nicht nur schlecht ist in
diesem sinne
das sagte also nicht die materie aber im
strengen sinne ist die formal ursache
des bösen nicht als wirkende ursache
aufzufassen
weil das moralisch bösen denke ich jetzt
denn wir werden sehen dass es in der
beraubung das heißt in dem von der
wirkenden ursache nicht getan besteht
darum pflegen die scholastik die ursache
des bösen defizienz zu nehmen wir hatten
ja thomas von aquin auch behandelt da
war das gute designs für
es war dieses graduelle modell sagt hier
ist irgendwie das ist gut
die frage ob es jetzt irgendwie auch ein
limit gibt oder ob es eine unendliche
perspektive ist wichtig ist dass es hier
begrenzt ist zu nichts und im bösen
wieder stehen wir dem guten und mehr
effizienz also das ist dann doch ein
bisschen dieses graduelle modell wie mir
scheint also dass das böse besteht in
einer beratung und jetzt sagt er hier
noch mal was über diese drei maler er
sagt man kann das über die metaphysische
physischen und moralischen sinne
auffassen
das metaphysische besteht in der
einfachen unvollkommenheit das ist die
endlichkeit das physische im leiden sei
es jetzt seelisch und körperlich und das
moralische in der sünde im bösen traum
wohl nun das physische und moralische
über nicht notwendig sind sind nicht
notwendig sie sind endlich das dem rad
jedenfalls unsere freiheit unterstellt
so genug ihre möglichkeit aufgrund der
ewigen wahrheiten weil die ewigen
wahrheiten sind die endlichkeit unserer
existenz aus der englischen unserer
existenz folgt zumindest dass es möglich
ist dass wir immer was böses tun oder
was böses erfahren aber es muss jetzt
sich unbedingt notwendiger weise das
seien ja ein unterschied die möglichkeit
es ist eigentlich fast notwendig es ist
fast notwendig weil es ist eigentlich
unvorstellbar dass wir ein leben leben
als ähnliche wesen bis 480 werden oder
wie auch immer in dem uns nichts
körperlich schlimmes widerfahren ist in
dem wir nichts schlimmes getan haben ich
meine vorstellbar wäre dass zum beispiel
bei menschen die kurz nach der geburt
sterben
gut da könnte man sagen dieses sterben
erst mal um physik um dann das so aber
jedenfalls wäre denkbar dass lebens er
kurz währt und eigentlich kein
körperliches übel ihm widerfährt und
nichts moralisches böses getan wird ja
dann wäre in diesem leben diese existenz
wären diese beiden maler nicht also
wirklich zur zur geltung gekommen kann
natürlich sagen wo dann früher tod ist
einmal um physikum wenn der tod jetzt
zeige ich mal einfach so schlagartig
cain ist gibt ja solche finden wo man
einfach so plötzlich stirbt kein leid
verspürt nichts unmoralisches getan
das wäre so möglicher fall wie mir
scheint also muss nicht notwendigerweise
sein wenn mensch so früh stirbt sehr
früh dann als kind würde nichts
moralisch böses tun können und wenn er
sehr schnell stirbt dann hat er
vielleicht kein physisches übernehmen
oder sein
die existenz
aber es wurde ja dieser mensch wurde ja
geboren dieser mensch wurde er geboren
und dass er geboren wurde dass er
geschäft wurde ist immer besser als er
nicht gewesen wäre
selbst wenn er nur eine minute liegt es
ist ein bisschen zynisch und sie merken
also die schiere existenz die schiere
das schiere auf die welt kommen ist
besser als nichts auf die willkommen
egal wie viele sekunden man lebt ja gut
aber da liegt natürlich wieder ein
pessimismus zugrunde
das wird dann eher schopenhauer sagen
oder die pille die fülle der
zahnschmerzen dein alter schritte und
alles was noch kommt der spaß ist das
scheint mir sehr schopenhauer risch zu
sein
also ab 30 dann sozusagen ja ok ja so ok
richtig ja ok richtig ja das ist das
sehe ich ein ja das überzeugt nicht
obwohl nun das physische und moralische
übel nicht notwendig sind so genügt ihre
möglichkeit aufgrund der ewigen
wahrheiten und da diese ungeheure region
der wahrheit alle möglichkeiten
umschließt so muss es unendlich viele
möglichen welten geben muss das übel
mehrere von ihnen eingang finden und
muss die beste aller welten es enthalten
hierdurch ist gott bestimmt worden das
übel zuzulassen
als gott ist durch die ideale natur
seines verstandes ist gezwungen fast
schon verstanden stand und will immer
der verstand gibt vor das übel
möglich ist das übel muss
notwendigerweise möglich sein
es kann nicht unmöglich sein wie keiner
welt es muss in der besten aller
möglichen welten möglich sein
notwendigerweise und jetzt kommt das war
der verstand der verstand sagt es muss
die möglichkeit des bösen bestehen
da kommt man nicht drum herum der
verstand fordert dass und gott muss um
frei zu haben in den verstand folgen und
jetzt kommt der wille ganz allgemein
besteht der wille in der neigung
irgendetwas entsprechend dem darin
enthaltenen gut zu tun
dieser wille wird ante cds also vorher
gehend antizipieren genannt wenn er
getrennt jedes gut in seinem für sich
sein betrachtet diese strecke sinne
strebt gott nach jedem gut als solchen
also all gültig und zwar tut er dies
vermögen des antizipieren den willens
hat eine tiefe sehnsucht danach alle
menschen zu heiligen und zu retten das
sind die auszuschließen und die
verdauung zu verhindern und kann sogar
sagen dieser wille sei wirksam an sich
per se das heißt der hat dass die
wirkung erfolgen müsste wenn sie nicht
durch einen stärkeren grund verhindert
würde dieser wille geht nämlich nicht
bis zum äußersten
da er sonst nie verfehlen würde seine
ganze wirkung hervorzubringen und gott
ja herr aller dinge ist also ein
bisschen schwierig kriegen sie da einen
sinn heraus und jetzt kommt das gute das
ist jetzt die schaltstelle des guten als
der wille ist bei leibnitz die
schaltstelle des guten
der verstand eigentlich auch aber der
wille vor
dieses prädikat der güte der verstand
geht auf die amerikaner mächtigkeit und
der wille geht dass alle güter wie kann
jetzt bleibt jetzt hier zeigen diesem
zitat dass gott trotz der endlichkeit
die vom verstand geboten ist dennoch all
gültig ist was macht denn der wille
die haare
mai
machen würde
das wäre eine möglichkeit ja aber ich
glaube es entscheiden ist das eher
getrennt jedes gute in seinem 40 sein
betrachtet
vielleicht gibt es noch ein zweites
zitat ja das müssen wir noch lesen dazu
also es geht es darum wieder wille auf
das gute gerichtet ist ganz und
unfehlbar ist die wirkung nur bei dem
als nachfolgend konsequenz bezeichnet
will
dieser wille ist er erfüllte und auf ihn
bezieht sich die regel dass man niemals
verfehlen wird das zu tun was man will
wofür man ist nur kann diese
nachfolgende zielstrebig und
entschiedene wille entsteht aus dem
widerstreit aller wohnungs antizipation
der das gute erstreben wieder das böse
zurückweisen aus dem zusammentreffen
aller partikularen leeren wohnungen
haben entsteht der gesamt wille wie der
mechanik zusammengesetzte bewegung aus
allen kräften die auf ein und denselben
beweglichen körper wirken resultiert
wohl in gleicher weise einer jeden
dieser kräftig genügt so weit es möglich
ist alles auf einmal zu träumen
tja jetzt anders als wie was macht jetzt
der universal wille gegensatz zum
partikulären willen
also die antizipierte wille der will
jedes gute konkret in der situation dass
das das dass das einzelne güter und der
allgemeine wille was will der der
verrechnet die güter die verschiedenen
gütern
er schaut wie wir angesichts dieser art
collage gott wollen könnte für die
menschen in der welt wie wir angesichts
der vielen strömungen den die kleine
vektoren sind wie wir dann die vektoren
aufaddieren zu einem gesamt vector so
kann man sie das glaube ich vorstellen
da gibt es bestrebungen zum guten da da
da und er summiert alles zusammen und
erhält dann eine richtung ein
gesamtzustand den besten die besten weg
um alle möglichst gerecht zu werden ich
glaube so kann man sich das vorstellen
also letztendlich der verstand
verrechnet das all gültige der wille
verrechnet dass aldi die tendenz der
allg mit den vorgaben des verstandes und
zur sorgt die beste konstellation in
diesen rahmenbedingungen so stell ich
mir jetzt vor und dann hätten wir eben
die alte jedoch bewahrt
angesichts den rahmenbedingungen des
verstandes zurück könnte man es
verstehen
hieraus ergibt sich dass gott das gute
in antizipieren
das bis dahin also das gute ist
praktisch ist absolut gute er will in
jeder situation das nächstliegende gute
das beste ist jetzt komparativ das ist
dann also im vergleich das beste aber in
folge war so will also angesichts der
gesamtumstände dass das böse anbelangt
so wie gott keineswegs das moralisch
böse oder auch nicht dass physischen
oder die leiden wenigsten sich unbedingt
und darum gibt es keine unbedingte fall
bestimmung zur verdauung und das
physische über wie gottes öfter als
strafe für eine verschuldung okay das
ist wie geht es also hier mal um
physikum folgt auf mal um
als strafe des öftern auch als
geeignetes mittel zur erreichung eines
bestimmten ziel es nämlich um größere
übel zu verhindern und größere güter
herbeizuführen
die strafe dient auch zur besserungen
zur abschreckung und das über die tür
wieder zu das gut stärker hervortreten
zu lassen das haben wir schon mal gehört
mitunter verschafft es auch dem der saal
eine höhere vollkommenheit wie der same
vorerkrankung einer art verderbnis
ausgesetzt ist
das ist jetzt wie bei hegel auch die
tägliche dialektik also hebel sagt der
same das samenkorn muss vergehen muss
zerstört werden damit dann die pflanze
oder der baum erblühen dass diese
dialektik etwas muss um überhaupt
entstehen zu können erstvergehen findet
man schon bei leitner als ein
hochspekulatives system wie sie sehen
sehr differenziert und nicht so trivial
dass man sagen könnte er leben ist ein
zyniker und so hatte ich schon dabei
etwas gedacht es ist wie so ein
räderwerk könnte man sich vorstellen in
dem alles ineinandergreift und das dann
am ende wie so eine rechenmaschine das
beste ergebnis ausspuckt angesichts
dieser notwendigen rahmenbedingungen so
kann man sich glaube ich bei leibnitz
gute vorstellen dass gute als rechen
produkt das gut als ergebnis einer
hochkomplexen kalkulation das ist das
gute bei leighton gott will das gute an
sich antizipieren er will das beste
nachfolgend als absicht und er will dass
indifferente unter füße über zuweilen
als mittel aber will das moralischen bin
war als conditio sine qua non als als
notwendige bedingung oder als
hypothetische notwendigkeit der an die
wahl des besten gebunden ist als gott
ist gezwungen das beste zu wählen
jetzt kann man sich fragen ist gott
darin da noch frei und bleibt sagt ja
gott ist dann frei wenn er gezwungen ist
das beste zu tun wenn er das was das
beste ist tun muss und diesen zwang
nicht als etwas äußeres empfindet
sondern als ein inneres prinzip dass
seine existenz ausmacht wenn er einfach
nur sein
cpm volk siegen würde gott das gar nicht
als zwang sinken das ist nur aus unserer
perspektive ist so aus unserer endlichen
perspektive dass gott ein zweiter leidet
dass gottes perspektive wäre das
ziemlich kein zwang ist einfach ein
reines eine selbst identität seine
eigenen prinzipien gerecht das ist eben
freiheit und die daher ist der
nachfolgende wille gottes dessen
gegenstand die sünde ist nur ein zu
lassen
all das ist noch eine unterscheidung
dann muss es eben zu lassen weil es der
verstand fordert aber es ist nicht
eigentlich einer der das will
besonders deshalb ein kompromiss
angesichts des verstandes immer noch das
beste
angesichts der komparative das beste
angesichts der beschränkungen die das
manometer physik uns vorgeht
ich meine es ist fällt die differenz von
gut und böse eigentlich aber der
kommilitone hat ihnen gesagt in dem
gottes den menschen verbietet vom baum
der erkenntnis zu essen das ist ja der
psychische zustand antizipiert er durch
das verbot das manometer physikum indem
er verbietet ist damit einhergehend das
er ist auch könnte insofern es könnte
zeigt sich dieses mal um metaphysik und
die möglichkeit geben und das ist das
entscheidende also das manometer
physikum ist nicht nur schlecht dürfen
uns nicht im negativen sinne vorstellen
sondern hat immer auch diese gute seite
ist eigentlich ein bono metaphysik um
genau besehen weil es eben die schöpfung
als prinzip es ist diese schöpfung
struktur erschöpfungs regel und die ist
eben eigentlich gut weil die schöpfung
ja gut ist und so wichtig alle darauf
kommt es mir anders zu zeigen
jetzt gibt es hier eben noch noch eine
letzte frage zum bösen lieder aus böse
alte der berühmte keppler und nach ihm
herr descartes in seinen briefen haben
beide von der natürlichen trägheit der
körper gesprochen
diese trägheit nun kann man als ein
vollendetes bild hunde als muster für
die ursprüngliche beschränktheit der
geschöpfe betrachten dann wird man sehen
dass die beraubung den formalen gehalt
der unvollkommenheiten und nun
zuträglich keiten der substanz und ihre
handlungen ausmacht also eine art privat
ions theorie des bösen ist böse ist hier
ein mangel
es ist die einschränkung eben als
endliches wesen gemäß dem prinzip das
manometer physikum ja ich glaube wir
brauchen
das ist doch wichtig dass man nochmal
lesen könnt ihr hier tritt letzten zeile
gott kommt nicht alles geben ohne sie
zum gott zu machen
er musste also stufen weil es
unterschiede in der vollkommenheit der
dinge ebenso beschränkung jeder art
geben also die geschöpfen musste
notwendigerweise endlich sein das
manometer physikum ist notwendig aber
dass mahle moral und das mal um physikum
ist eben möglich notwendigerweise
möglich muss aber nicht unbedingt jetzt
sein weil dann wäre ja gott ja nicht
mehr gültig dass also die die
notwendigkeit des mahnung mit der physik
und wir wollen jetzt gar nicht weiter
auf diese verschiedenen sachen eingehen
sie können das gern noch mal weiter
anschauen jetzt gehen wir zu einem
anderen denke jetzt gehen wir wirklich
vom rationalismus ihn mitten in die
aufklärung jean jacques rousseau der 100
jahre nach leibnitz gelebt hat und auch
hier haben wir noch eine schrift
zugrunde liegen die abhandlungen
ursprung und die grundlagen der
ungleichheit unter den menschen und wir
wollen uns folgende frage stellen
wodurch tritt nach muss so das böse in
die welt in welche inter subjektiven und
selbst bezüglichen einstellung liegt das
gute das böse begründet wie verhalten
sich natur und vernunft zustand
zueinander mit blick auf das verhältnis
von gut und böse
und jetzt natur einfach zustand das ist
ähnlich wie beim paradies erzählungen
die natur zustand ist der pre japanische
zustand der vernunft zustand ist der
postler passage zustanden euro
ich frage ob man jemals hat sagen hören
dass ein wilder in freiheit auch nur
daran gedacht hätte sich über das leben
zu beklagen und sich den tod zu geben
ein urteile also mit weniger hochmut auf
welcher seite das wahrhafte elend ist
nichts wäre im gegenteil so elend
gewesen wären durch aufklärung
verblendeter von leidenschaft gequälter
will der mensch über ein von dem
seidigen verschiedene zustand räsonierte
durch eine sehr weise vorsehung sollten
sich die fähigkeiten die ihr die
möglichkeit nach hatte erst mit dem
gelegenheiten sie ausüben entwickeln
damit sie für ihn jeder überflüssig und
eine belastung vor derzeit noch zu spät
und unnütz im bedarfsfalle bären dem
instinkt allein hatte alles was er
braucht um im naturzustand zu leben
einige bildeten vernunft hat er nur was
er braucht man diese gesellschaft zu
leben also hier geht es jetzt darum
natürlich auch wieder wie kommt das böse
die welt leibnitz sagt jetzt teilweise
durch die vernunft durch groß sagt durch
die vernunft in dem wir rationalisieren
vergleichen wir uns mit anderen menschen
wir wollen besser sein als sie wir
entwickeln unser mitleid zurück im
naturzustand sagt russo hatten wir
mitleid ein natürliches gefühl der
verbundenheit mit anderen wesen und
dieses mitleid wird durch die
entwicklung der vernunft im vernunft
zustand also den modernen gesellschaft
immer weiter verdunkelt und an die
stelle des mitleids und auch an die
stelle der selbst bliebe die nach muss
so etwas gesundes ist wir mögen uns wir
sind mit uns im reinen dass die
selbstliebe an die stelle diese
natürlichen selbst lieben des mitleids
tritt die eigenliebe am porträt also
truppe ist ja auch kopper die
property heißt ja auch eigentum antritt
dann diese konkurrenz dieser
kapitalismus könnte man schon sagen
diese ganzen schlimme dinge die kommen
mit der vernunft erst ins spiel
natürlich kann man sich umgedreht fragen
wo es dann das gute zu finden wir haben
jetzt wieder alles nur vom bösen her da
vom verfall her betrachtet zeigt weiter
ist scheint zunächst so dass die
menschen jedem zu jedem zustand im
naturzustand dass sie untereinander
weder irgendeine art moralischer
beziehung noch erkannte pflichten hatten
weder gut noch böse sein konnten und
weder laster noch tun hatten
es sei denn man nimmt diese wird in
einem physischen sinn und entlastet die
eigenschaften im individuum die seine
eigene haltung schaden können und touren
in jene die zu ihr beitragen können in
welchem fall man denjenigen am
tugendhaften nehmen müssten
den einfachen antrieb metro an wenigsten
widerstände aber auch wenn wir uns vom
gewöhnlichen sie nicht entfernen ist es
angebracht das urteil dass wir über eine
derartige lage fällen können
aufzuschieben und anderen vorteilen sie
misstrauen bis man mit der waage in der
hand geprüft hat ob es unter den
zivilisierten menschen mehr trugen als
laster gibt oder ob ihre tugenden
vorteilhafter sind als ihre laster
unheilvolle oder ob der fortschritt
ihrer kenntnisse eine hinreichende
entschädigung für die übel ist die sich
wechselseitig in dem maße zu fügen
indem sie sich über das gute
unterrichten dass sie einander tun
sollten oder ob sie alles in allem
genommen nicht in einer glücklichen lage
wären weder von jemandem übels zu
befürchten noch gutes laufen zu haben
als sich einer universellen abhängigkeit
unterworfen zu haben und sich zu
verpflichten alles von dir ins empfangen
die sich nicht verpflichten ihn etwas zu
geben
das ist in der tat
halte der naturzustand ist
möglicherweise ein in dem es gut und
böse noch gar nicht gibt erinnert jetzt
an den psychischen zustand vom baum der
erkenntnis wurde noch nicht gegessen
tja aber ist diese diese dieser
naturzustand der er natürlich auch nur
ein konstrukt ist das ist eine
vorstellung von rousseau ist der jetzt
wirklich gut zu nehmen
und jetzt sagte aber was ist denn jetzt
das gute es gibt im übrigen noch ein
anderes prinzip das haus nicht bemerkt
hat haupt ist für rousseaus um gegen
gegenspieler haupt sagt ja der mensch
ist dem menschen ein wolf ein
pessimistisches bild
also der würde sagen der mensch wenn man
irgendwo aufeinander loslässt im
naturzustand der zerfleischt sich
deswegen brauchen wir eine art von
vernunft zustand sag jetzt mal wir
brauchen den staat um dieses verhältnis
zu regeln sagt russo das stimmt
überhaupt nicht wenn wir den menschen
natürlich lassen und dass ich dann
finden wir anhaltspunkte von einer
bestimmten güter zu sprechen er sagt
nämlich es gibt ein prinzip das da es
den menschen gegeben worden ist um unter
bestimmten umständen die cremigkeit
seiner eigenliebe altersarmut hoppe und
das verlangen nach selbsterhaltung vor
der entstehung dieser liebe zu mildern
den eifer den er für sein wohlbefinden
hängt durch einen angeborenen
wiederwählen mäßig zahlen mit menschen
leiden zu sehen ich glaube nicht dass
irgendein widerspruch befürchten zu
müssen wenn ich den menschen diese
einzige natürliche typen zu sprechen wie
der überstand spannte herabsetzen der
menschlichen tugenden anzuerkennen
gezwungen gewesen ist ich spreche vom
mitleid eine disposition die für so
schwache und so vielen übeln ausgesetzt
gewesen wie wir sind angemessen ist
allen menschen umso universelle und umso
nützlicher tugend als sie bei ihm dem
gebrauch jede reflexion vorausgeht und
eine so natürliche dass selbst die tiere
manchmal wahrnehmbare zeichen davon
geben
ich sehe hier plötzlich nehmen diesen
texten zu meinen anderen seminaren zu
den bösen lidl in jedem zitat aber jetzt
auch zu einem seminar über den geist der
tiere ist auch eine spannende frage die
ich mir mit der ich mich immer am
dienstagnachmittags beschäftigen ob
tiere
überhaupt geist haben ob tiere zu
höheren kognitiven fähigkeiten der lage
sind muss so sagt ja sie sind zum
mitleid in der lage er sagt nämlich hier
ohne von der zärtlichkeit der mütter für
ihre jungen und von den gefahren zu
sprechen denen sie trotzen um sie vor
diesen zu beschützen beobachtet man
täglich den widerwillen der pferde einem
lebenden körper mit füßen zu treten
ein tier geht nicht ohne humor an einem
toten tier seiner art vorüber
es gibt sogar welche die ihn in eine art
von begräbnis zuteil werden lassen und
das traurige brüllendes fliesst wenn es
in ein schlachthaus hineinkommt weist
auf den eindruck hin den es von dem
entsetzlichen schauspieler erhält das
sich ihm eröffnet dass die klassische
frage für das seminar geiste tiere sind
tiere dass solche nackten wirklich in
der lage oder ist es nicht nicht
anthropozän trish in der antrieb an
throm kommunistischen anderen
humoristische sichtweise dass wir selbst
etwas in das tier hineinlegen was ist
gar nicht hat aber jedenfalls sagt
mitleid ist ein grundsätzliches prinzip
und das noch zum schluss hatte mitleid
dass es natürlich das finden wir in der
ganzen natur das ist das prinzip des
guten nach rosso letztendlich das
mitleid und dagegen steht die vernunft
die vernunft erzeugt die eigenliebe und
die reflexion verstärkt sie sie lässt
den menschen auf sich selbst
zurückziehen sie trennt ihn von allem
was ihm lästig ist und ihn betrügt die
philosophie isolierten ihres weges sagt
er beim anblick eines leiden menschen
insgeheim stirbt wenn du willst ich bin
in sicherheit
nur mehr die gefahren für die ganze
gesellschaft können den ruhigen schlaf
dass wieder so viele stören oder ihn aus
seinem bett reisen und kann seinen
mitmenschen unter seinem fenster
ungestraft umbringen er braucht sich nur
die ohren zuzuhalten und sich ein paar
argumente zurecht zu legen um die natur
die sich in ihm empört daran zu hindern
in mit dem zu identifizieren die man bei
euch links ermordet der philosoph jetzt
vom fenster unter ihm wird jemand
ermordung der philosoph der macht sich
dann so ein paar schöne gedanken und
rechtfertigt das warum das jetzt alles
schon zu ok ist wer will der mensch hat
diese bewohnt
wird dieses bewundernswerte talent nicht
und aus mangel an weisheit und vernunft
zieht man ihn stets sich unbesonnen dem
ersten gefühl der menschlichkeit
erlassen
bei den unruhen den streitereien in den
straßen läuft der pöbel zusammen der
kluge menschen entfernt sich erst die
kanadier sind die marktweiber welche die
kämpfenden trennen und die
rechtschaffene leute daran
hintereinander umzubringen
ja also das ist ein anti elitärer es
sagt der philosoph und das ist ja diese
gesellschaftskritik der philosoph der
sich nur auf die vernunft bezieht genug
eben nicht das gute die vernunft ist
nicht mehr das prinzip des guten das ist
glaube ich eine ganz wichtige erkenntnis
barroso sollen sie ist vielmehr sie kann
vielmehr ein grund des bösen sein warum
was macht die vernunft sie ermöglicht es
uns uns in fantasien zu verlieren und
selbst zu belügen und selbst etwas
vorzumachen scheinwelten zu konstruieren
die man scheinbar moralisch begründen
kann kannten dieses phänomen des
phänomens vernünftiges also die vernunft
die rechtfertigt sich irgendwie schon so
wie sie will und dabei geht die
moralität verloren das ist jetzt noch
eine andere perspektive auf das gute
wir werden im nächsten sitzung noch
einmal kurz auf russo zu sprechen komme
ich habe noch ein paar zitate hier hier
sagt er ist also ganz gewiss dass das
mitleid ein natürliches gefühl ist dass
das in jedem individuum die aktivität
der selbst die gemäßigt zur
wechselseitigen erhaltung einer ganzen
art beitrag ist veranlasst uns ohne
reflexion zur unterstützung derer die
wir leiden sehen im naturzustand
vertritt ist die stelle der gesetze der
sitten und der tugend mit dem vorteil
dass keiner versucht wird seiner süßen
stimme den gehorsam zu versagen
es wird jeden kräftigen wilden davon
abbringen einem schwachen kindern
gebrechlichen kreis sein mühsam
erworbenen lebensunterhalt wegzunehmen
wenn er selbst die in seidigen anderswo
zu finden können hofft anstelle jener
erhaben maxime der deutschen nicht
erschlossenen gerechtigkeit tue anderen
wie du willst das man dir wohl gibt es
das mitleid der menschen diese andere
maxi mit der natürlichen gute 1
damals das stichwort natürliche güte das
ist das stichwort für unser seminar
natürliche könnte ein wir werden dieses
wort noch mal hören bei philips die
financial times spricht von natürlich
gute also es gibt in der natur selbst
etwas gutes und nicht nur in der
vernunft also sagen die gegenposition zu
platon der tendenziell ja sagt in der
materie in der natur ist das böse zu
finden tendenziell holzschnittartige
holt so nein gerade nicht in der materie
in der natur in dem vergänglichen der
fußes da ist gerade das gute zu finden
stellt also planern auf dem kopf
gewissermaßen diese natürlich würde die
viel weniger vollkommen aber vielleicht
nützlicher ist als die vorhergehende
sorge für dein wohl mit dem geringst
möglichen schaden für andere
hier sehen wir bald eine ganz neue sicht
auf das gute und die werden in der
nächsten sitzung noch mal kurz behandeln
bevor wir dann auf immanuel kant
eingehen werden da eine ganz ganz
zentrale theorie des gut entwickelt hat
indem er sich auf den willens begriff
konzentriert dass er gut ist nur ein
guter wille geht als ins objekt hinein
weder die ideen die über allem stehe
sind das gute noch die materie natur
sollen
der wille im subjekt selbst also eine
wendung ins innerliche sind neue
dimension und wir werden eben diesen
willens begriff behandeln und auch noch
auf die theorie des höchsten gut zu
sprechen kommen dann bis zur nächsten
sitzung